let's just get our heads back in the
space we've been getting this
spreadsheet to do lots of the mentor
crunch work that we usually do okay so
if you can't remember the whole
structure of this right
you've got hours of employment up here
these two rows and why did we have two
rows for again they are labeled like we
have two different kinds but why should
I separate them that's my question why
bother fantastic thank you these are
actually going to be early different
amounts of money right because of it
over time I think we said time in half
didn't wait something like that okay so
then do you remember and you can have a
look if you are click down and check out
one of these four years down here these
things down here that's not really 37
that just happens to be 37 at the moment
and really there's a formula there's an
equation behind there that's actually
working out that number so this one
normally hours add up this row overtime
hours which I'm finding right now this
one here is adding up the road below and
so on okay so I think that's that do you
remember where we how we got all these
numbers in a lot kind of thing so far so
good okay no here's a typical question
for you right I think this last cell
band that one bit okay that's usually
kind of the question right it's like you
know he's his question one it's like
dossie works so and so and so a lot it
gives you all these details about his
hours right and then it says you know
question a how much does yeah okay so
that's a pretty typical question so I
guess the punchline would be our final
number there $625 60 now often what
they'll do is to take one situation and
then they'll ask you a slightly
different question with reference to it
right so they might ask for instance how
much would he have to earn
right what hourly rate would he need if
instead of what was that six hundred and
something dollars right suppose in that
one week is like I need to I need to buy
something I need something expensive and
like you know I absolutely have to get
an iPhone 6 but or whatever it is okay
and so I need actually how much isn't
that fizzing spices there are no do you
know okay so that's a bit well okay so
do you know how much would it be like if
you just bought it outright 1300 okay
well they don't really need to get let's
say 1300 la Rapid City's offensive
friend okay fine let's just go with that
number okay so I'm going to teach you a
way to treat for how to get that right
why don't you do is shake sure you are
on your cursor is on that cell there the
one which will get the 1300 total that's
what we want okay now here's what we
could do what we could do is we could
take that hourly rate and we could
change it we could make it safe 14
dollars okay and when you hit enter okay
so he's earned a bit more right I think
I changed the for the hourly right
behind 40 cents an hour and when you
crunch through all of these formulas
here aver literally you'll earn an extra
$20 that week okay questions okay thank
you I sweat come on how much 1000 or
just just okay all right now let's
change it to that Big O which which is a
bit more reasonable that's still a lot
of money okay is it 99 cents really I
think it's just dollars doesn't matter
we can change it later on
okay now we own an extra $20 that's nice
but it's not it's not what we need so
what some would give me a ballpark he
wants to give me a guess what do you
think we should try what a linear a
would you like me to try and input nine
dollars okay so I want to suggest nine
dollars is probably not gonna give us a
good outcome because all right that's
less so let's take us away let's try 20
I think 20 is a reasonable quantity to
try all right now we're getting more
yeah all right how much better do you
think we need to go 25 well okay now
that'd be pretty good if you could earn
25 by 2 now okay but most of us not
gonna be able to earn that much we've
gone over right now we can do better
than this all of this guesswork the
computer can do it for you so here's
what you do click on that number there
that total pay cell and then this is a
bit fancy I want you to go up to the top
and you can see usually your default is
um you've got the Home tab selected I
want you to go all the way over to the
data tab and click on that okay now just
before you touch anything I want you to
look at all of these different options
here all kinds of weird crazy stuff and
probably you don't know what half of it
does okay and that's all right there's
so many options here the particular one
I want us to look at is over here all
the way on the right where it says this
green question mark it says what-if
analysis okay so what if analysis the
whole idea is it's asking the question
well what if right what if I wanted to
get 999 dolls down at the end rather
than 600 or 400 whatever so I want you
to click on that icon what-if analysis
and then you should have these three
options coming up is that me and not
slowly I mean if you see those yeah good
okay the particular one where you want
is the one in the middle
it says goal seek goal seek which
unsurprisingly is about seeking goals
okay so click on that now look at what
just just come up there's this little
little window here it says goal seek
right so what we want is and you can see
the cell that you had highlighted before
now it's what the ants running around it
right we want to set that cells value to
what do we want 900 900 dollars okay so
type that in nine nine nine what the
spreadsheet is going to do is it's gonna
crunch through numbers until it hits 999
okay but there's one more piece of
information we need look at that little
bit down bottom there
yeah by changing a particular cell so
we're gonna say look I want 999 that's
the goal that I'm seeking and what I
want you to adjust is we would try to
adjust the hourly rate right so put your
cursor in there you can see it's
flashing under changing cell and then
you're gonna yeah you can even actually
type in b7 we'll do exactly that right
so I'm just gonna I'm just in this
highlight there alright now before I
press ok
what's it doing it's trying to get this
said I heard Renee 9 and the way it's
gonna do it is by mucking around with
the value of this cell which is what we
were doing but really slowly okay so now
you can enter and it's found a solution
for you it's found an exact solution to
the scent okay did you see that goal
seeking with cell d7 found a solution
Talia died 999 it got it okay so that's
really cool it can actually do these
kinds of things for you and you don't
need to kind of muck around in your
calculator that's the kind of thing
that's perfectly suited to a computer so
you get it to do it all right